[Música]
Bienvenidos a enlaces Centroamérica este
capítulo desde ciudad de Guatemala a mis
espaldas el Palacio de justicia y la
torre de tribunales iconos de un sistema
judicial que ha sido señalado de
favorecer la corrupción
en Guatemala cerca de 30 jueces y
Fiscales viven en el exilio luego de
haber abandonado de súbito el país por
temor a ser criminalizados
el más reciente informe transparencia
internacional sobre el índice de
percepción de la corrupción ubica a
Guatemala en el puesto 150 de 180 países
del Mundo una caída en picada hacia la
corrupción de 59 escaños en 12 años
Naciones Unidas y organismos
internacionales como Human Rights watch
advierten que la corrupción penetró el
sistema judicial para dejar impunes a
los corruptos mediante la persecución de
ciertos jueces y Fiscales el diputado de
candidato presidencial Bernardo Arévalo
Explica el fenómeno tenemos un sistema
en donde las instituciones de Justicia
que son creadas para procurar justicia y
para lograr que se defienda a la
sociedad de los elementos criminales y
corruptos ahora está cooptada por
elementos criminales y corruptos y se
pone a funcionar para perseguir a
aquellas personas que han tenido algún
tipo de actuación y gestión en contra de
los intereses de estos grupos político
criminales la reciente fricción
diplomática entre Guatemala y Colombia
partió del anuncio de El fiscal
guatemalteco Rafael currucciche de
emprender acciones legales en contra
Iván Velázquez el ministro colombiano de
defensa sin pruebas contundentes que lo
incriminen por presuntamente conocer a
fondo sobre los sobornos de odebrecht en
Guatemala el ataque contra Velázquez se
percibe como una venganza de una red de
actores corruptos que él desenmascaro
cuando era el jefe de la sisic la
comisión internacional contra la
impunidad en Guatemala el anuncio de la
Fiscalía de las acciones contra Iván
Velázquez son tal vez el ejemplo que
resume de una manera sintética pero
perfecta esta noción de la perversión de
las instituciones del estado que se
logra mediante la cooptación otro de los
casos que más ha llamado la atención de
la comunidad internacional ha sido la
criminalización reconocido periodista
José Rubén Zamora por la misma fiscalía
que le abrió una investigación al
ministro colombiano Iván Velázquez
Zamora fue el fundador de el periódico
ganador del premio internacional de
periodismo rey de España en 2020 como el
medio más destacado de iberoamérica por
sus denuncias e investigaciones de
entramados de corrupción en Guatemala
actualmente Zamora suma más de medio año
en prisión por presunto lavado de dinero
chantaje y tráfico de influencias
continúa preso
el Ministerio Público puede determinar
la cantidad de tiempo que se que él
tenga que estar obviamente se va a
interponer un recurso buscando que un
tribunal que sea más independiente
porque este tribunal se sabía de
antemano que no es independiente y que
responde a los intereses de la alianza
oficialista que es la que está en este
momento gobernando en Guatemala y que lo
que está haciendo es limitando y
controlando y reprimiendo a la prensa
pero no solo a la prensa también a los
operadores de noticia tras su captura en
julio de 2022 José Rubén Zamora ha
tenido que cambiar cuatro veces de
abogado porque alegan persecución
judicial de la fiscalía también Zamora
denunció que el juez que dirige su
proceso amenazó públicamente a su
testigo principal según los allegados
del reconocido periodista su juicio es
un caso montado en revancha por destapar
escándalos de corrupción que salpican al
presidente Alejandro yamatei y
obviamente encontramos con que había un
gobierno que estaba incómodo porque
todos los días salía a relucir un caso
nuevo de corrupción que el Ministerio
Público no investigaba Y en vez de eso
sí se dedican a investigar a un
periodista por supuesto tráfico eh Por
supuesto lavado de dinero para poner un
ejemplo una de las denuncias que publicó
el periódico envuelve Al actual gobierno
del presidente Alejandro yamatei en un
caso de corrupción que permanece impune
la presunta participación del presidente
de la recepción de so por parte de
empresarios rusos para la operación de
una Mina en el país que fue denunciado
por el ahora ex fiscal y en el exilio
Juan Francisco Sandoval en noviembre de
2022 el departamento de estado de
Estados Unidos confirmó una sospecha del
ex fiscal anticorrupción de Guatemala
Juan Francisco Sandoval que los
dirigentes rusos de una mina a cielo
abierto en Guatemala habrían sobornado
con millones de dólares al ejecutivo con
tal de mantener sus extracciones de
níquel a toda Costa si bien las empresas
Fueron sancionadas por Estados Unidos
con la ley magnitsky el fiscal Sandoval
que quiso investigar al presidente
yamatei tuvo que escapar del país la
fiscal general Consuelo porras reemplazó
al fiscal Sandoval con un fiscal de su
entera confianza Rafael curruchiche
tanto porras como corruchichi están
sancionados en la lista de Engel de los
Estados Unidos por frenar
investigaciones en Casos de corrupción
Lo que sucede es que ahora el Ministerio
Público o la fiscalía y el organismo
judicial en contubernio con Alianza
incluso con el mismo gobierno pues
plantean persecución en contra de
operadores de Justicia que han
investigado corrupción con el propósito
de liberar a otros actores que están
acusados de corrupción de hace años es
decir generar impunidad en France 24
solicitamos formalmente entrevistas con
la fiscalía o el Ministerio Público y
con magistrados de la corte
constitucional para conocer su versión
pero ambas solicitudes nos fueron
negadas la preocupación por la profunda
crisis de corrupción en el sistema
judicial de Guatemala se agudiza de Cara
a las elecciones generales del próximo
25 de junio donde se deberá escoger
presidente diputados y alcaldes
así terminamos este enlace Centroamérica
en la cámara estuvo mi colega Aurora
bayú recuerde que este y otros programas
los pueden ver en France 24.com